In a fair democracy everyone's vote should
count equally, but the method that the United
States uses to elect its president, called
the electoral college, violates this principle
by making sure that some people's votes are
more equal than others.
The Electoral College is, essentially, the
538 votes that determine who wins the presidency.
If these votes were split evenly across the
population every 574,000 people would be represented
by one vote.
But that's not what happens because the Electoral
College doesn't give votes to people, only
states.
Which has some unfair consequences.
For example there are 11,500,000 people in
Ohio so, to fairly represent them, it should
get 20 electoral votes.
But the Electoral college doesn't give Ohio
20 votes, it only gets 18 -- two less than
it should.
Where'd those other votes go?
To states like Rhode Island.
Plucky Rhode Island has 1.1 million people
in it, so it should have about two votes,
but instead it gets four!
Those extra two votes that should be representing
Ohioans go to representing Rhode Islanders
instead?
Why?
Because, according to the rules of the electoral
college, every state, no matter how few people
live there, gets three votes to start with
before the rest are distributed according
to population.
Because of this rule there are a lot of states
with a few people that should only have one
or two votes for president but instead get
three or four.
So Georgians, Virginians, Michiganders & Jerseyites
are each missing one vote,
Pennsylvanians, North Carolinians, Ohioans
& Hoosiers are missing two, Floridians are
missing 4, New Yorkers, 5, Texans 6, and Californians
are 10 short of what they should get.
Because of this vote redistribution, the Electoral
College essentially pretends that fewer people
live where they do and more people live where
they don't.
An American who lives in one of these states,
has their vote for president count for less
than an American who lives in one of these
states.
In some cases the Electoral College bends
the results just a little, but if you live
in a particularly large or small state, it
bends them a lot.
One Vermonter's vote, according to the Electoral
College is worth three Texans' votes.
And one Wyomingite's vote is worth four Californians'.
Now, hold on there son, you might be saying
to yourself right now: you're missing the
whole point of the electoral college.
It's to protect the small states from the
big states.
Give the small states more voting power and
the presidential candidates will have to pay
them more attention in an election.
If that's the goal of the electoral college,
it's failing spectacularly.
Here's a graph showing the number of visits
the presidential Candidates paid to each of
the states in the last two months of the previous
election.
If it looks like there are a few states missing,
you're right.
Only 18 of the 50 states received even a single
visit from a candidate.
And just two of those states, Mane and New
Hampshire have very small populations.
The area of the country with the most small
states is conspicuously missing.
The Electoral College doesn't make candidates
care about small states.
But, interestingly the biggest states, California,
Texas and New York are missing as well so
what's going on?
Looking closer, just four states, Ohio, Florida,
Pennsylvania and Virginia received a majority
of the candidates' attention during the election.
And if you follow the money, it's the same
story.
Why do candidates spend so much money and
time in so few states?
Because the way the electoral college works
forces them to do so.
The elections are winner-take-all.
As long as a candidate gets just over 50%
of the popular vote in a state he wins 100%
of that state's electoral votes.
That means winning by millions of citizens'
votes is no better than winning by a single
vote.
So candidates are safe to ignore states where
they poll with big margins.
Instead, the electoral college makes candidates
intensely interested in the needs of just
a few states with close races, to the detriment
of of almost all Americans, which is why it
should be abolished.
But wait!
You might say, won't abolishing the electoral
college and voting directly for president
cause candidates to spend all their time in
big cities?
That wouldn't fair to most Americans either.
This sounds like a reasonable fear, but ignores
the mathematical reality of population distribution.
There are 309 million people in the United
States, only 8 million of which live in New
York, the largest city by far.
That's 2.6% of the total population.
But after New York, the size of cities drops
fast.
LA has 3.8 million and Chicago has 2.7 but
you can't even make it to the tenth biggest
city, San Jose before you're under a million
people.
These top ten cities added together are only
7.9% of the popular vote hardly enough to
win an election.
And even winning the next 90 biggest cities
in the United States all the way down to Spokane
is still not yet 20% of the total population.
So unless there's a city with a few hundred
million people hiding somewhere in America
that's been left out of the census, the idea,
that a candidate can just spend their campaign
Jetting between New York, LA and Chicago while
ignoring everyone else and still become president
is mathematically ludicrous.
Want to see the real way to unfairly win?
How YOU can become President with only 22%
of the popular vote by taking advantage of
the Electoral College today!
Don't believe that's possible in a democracy?
Just watch:
Here's the action plan: win the votes of the
people who count the most and ignore the people
who count the least.
Start with Wyoming, the state where 0.18%
of Americans live but who get 0.56% of the
electoral college votes for president.
And, because it's a winner take all system,
you don't need all of them to vote for you,
just half plus one or 0.09%.
Next up is the District of Columbia where
winning 0.1% of the population also gets you
an additional 0.56% of the electoral college.
Then add in wins in Vermont, and North Dakota,
and Alaska.
Notice how the votes your getting to win the
presidency go up much faster than the percent
of the population who voted for you because
of the Electoral College's rules.
Next is South Dakota, then Delaware, Montana,
Rhode Island, New Hampshire, Maine, Hawaii,
Idaho, Nebraska, West Virginia, New Mexico,
Nevada, Utah, Kansas, Arkansas, Mississippi,
Iowa, Connecticut, Oklahoma, Oregon, Kentucky,
Louisiana, South Carolina, Alabama, Colorado,
Minnesota, Wisconsin, Maryland, Missouri,
Tennessee, Arizona, Indiana, Massachusetts,
Virginia, and New Jersey.
Congratulations, by taking advantage of unfair
rules and winning states, not people, you've
won a majority in the Electoral College even
though 78% of the population voted against
you.
This is not Democracy, this is indefensible.
While this particular scenario is unlikely,
if you have a voting system that allows losers
to win, you shouldn't be surprised when they
do.
Not once, not twice, but thrice in American
history the candidate with the most votes
from the people actually lost because of the
electoral college.
Three errors in 55+ elections is a failure
rate of 5%.
Would anyone tolerate a sport where, by a
quirk of the rules, there was a 5% chance
that the loser would win?
Not likely.
Given how much more important electing the
president of the United States is, that's
a rather dangerously high percentage of the
time to get it wrong.
If we abolish the Electoral College and simply
let citizens vote for the president directly,
all of these problems will go away and everyone's
vote will be equal.